[Musique]
thouars et bienvenue à tous dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo l'émission
de la rédaction pour revenir sur
l'actualité départementale de la semaine
voici lé titre en participant adversaire
dans la bonne humeur en elle le
traditionnel trophée des entreprises
s'est déroulée jeudi à saint quentin en
yvelines les salariés du territoire se
sont affrontés sur des épreuves de golf
et de course à pied notamment un
événement où l'ambiance primer sur le
résultat encore et toujours la cgt ne
lâche rien la centrale était mobilisée
jeudi sur le territoire de saint quentin
en yvelines opérations de tractage et
rencontres auprès des salariés des
collectivités pour défendre le service
public
à quelques mois des élections
professionnelles nous recevons sonia
porot responsable départemental de la
cgt
enfin dans le reste de l'actualité
retour sur l'inauguration du nouveau
sporting de bouygues à guyancourt par la
ministre des sports laura flessel ou
encore de nombreux événements et
animations autour de la semaine du
développement durable à saint quentin en
yvelines
c'est devenu une tradition au printemps
désormais le trophée des entreprises
organisé entre le vélodrome nationale et
l'île de loisirs par l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines
une course contre la montre destinée aux
acteurs économiques et administratifs du
territoire plus de 600 participants ont
transpiré pour cette onzième édition
parmi eux nicolas landry de la course à
pied du golf du radeau ou encore du vtt
six épreuves pour ce onzième trophée des
entreprises sur un parcours de plus de 7
km au coeur de l'île de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines un défi éprouvant
cette année
par rapport à l'un des miens fait on
ramait du goût tous les tickets pas sa
carrière qui nous guide et si tu sais je
pense que le run and bike à la fin oui
il fallait inverser en courant c'était
un peu casse-gueule pense le radeau
particulièrement cette année en fait
c'était le plus physique de toutes les
épreuves
parce que lors pourquoi voilà des grands
groupes des pme ou les services de
communes du territoire de nombreuses
équipes venues avec leurs supporters
pour porter les valeurs du sport et de
l'entreprise les moeurs du sport c'est
bien sûr être le meilleur mais en même
temps il ya beaucoup de sport d'équipé
où là il faut pas être seulement le
meilleur il faut être celui qui apporte
le plus de valeur ajoutée au groupe est
en fait on retrouve cette logique
aujourd'hui de donc elle est dans
l'entreprise
à quelques mois de la ryder cup cette
édition du trophée des entreprises
avaient enfilé les couleurs de la
compétition mondiale de golf grève des
cheminots épisode 13 samedi et dimanche
le trafic sera perturbé une nouvelle
fois dans les transports en commun pour
vous rendre au partir de saint quentin
en yvelines pensez à vous renseigner à
prévoir éventuellement des alternatives
pour certains de vos trajets les lignes
n ai eu du transilien et leur rer c
seront forcément impacter lors de la
dernière grève en milieu de semaine en
moyenne trois transilien sur cinq
étaient en circulation défense des
services publics et campagne pour les
prochaines élections professionnelles la
cgt mener une journée d'actions jeudi à
saint quentin en yvelines le syndicat a
programmés notamment plusieurs
opérations de tractage devant la gare de
montigny ou devant le bâtiment du
conseil départemental à guyancourt le
récit de cette journée avec ce reportage
cette horde actions du matin jusqu'au
milieu de l'après-midi pour la défense
des services publics la cgt ne lâche
rien plusieurs semaines après le début
du mouvement des cheminots est alors que
la convergence des luttes reste un échec
pour le moment le syndicat continue
d'occuper le terrain social à saint
quentin en yvelines
que ça soit la sncf que ça soit toute la
santé dernière en date les allocations
hier pour nous c'est l'ensemble des
services publics au sens large pas que
ce statut mais les caf les ces femmes
qui sont en train de fermer il ya 400
points dans le département qui sont en
train de fermer la politique du
gouvernement en ligne de mire pour faire
passer les messages il faut bien sûr
mobiliser pas forcément simple à l'heure
d'aller au travail
les gens sont quand même sympa ils nous
disent bonjour ils prennent le papier
donc nous déjà en est content s'ils le
prennent c'est qu'ils vont prendre le
temps de le lire
après on sent parfois quand même une
certaine résignation rassemblement
devant la gare auprèsde axes routiers
majeurs mais aussi auprès des salariés
de la fonction publique
la centrale est en campagne et l'enjeu
est de taille le syndicat joue sa
première place lors des élections
professionnelles en décembre prochain
dont la confiance dans le fait qu'on va
rester au premier
le premier sujet nous qui nous occupe
c'est le niveau de la participation
parce qu'on voit qu aux élections
politiques
il ya des problèmes de participation
électorale ça peut être le cas aussi aux
élections professionnelles donc le
message qu'on veut faire passer c'est
que si on veut continuer de servir la
démocratie au travail il faut vraiment
que nos collègues vote en 2017 la cgt
avait perdu sa première place dans le
privé au profit de la cfdt
le taux de participation était alors
inférieur à 43 % et pour approfondir
cette thématique sonia porot est avec
nous en plateau bon soir dans ça vous
est la responsable départementale delà
de la cgt jeudi cette journée d'action
dont on vient voir de voir le reportage
c'était principalement pour occuper le
terrain montrer que c'est encore vous
les numéros 1 sur le département en tout
cas on en termes de proximité avec les
salariés d'implantation territoriales
oui je pense que la cgt est
l'organisation syndicale qui travaillent
le plus ces questions là mais le vrai
objectif de cette journée qui était
quand même assez exceptionnel c'était
surtout d'aller à la rencontre des
salariés de les informer de leur
proposer une pétition de défendre les
services publics et d'informer aussi
voilà des élections à venir les salariés
concernés
quel a été l'accueil du coup sûr sur le
terrain que vous ont dit les salariés à
bas un accueil globalement très très
chaleureux et est intéressé on a eu
beaucoup de salariés qui sont parfois
revenu le midi sur le point fixe à la
gare signer la pétition après avoir eu
le tract le matin voilà beaucoup de
mercy de bon courage et s'il ya un peu
de résignation aussi on l'a entendue
dans le reportage était une militante
qui le quai le disais on a l'impression
que les gens vous écoute effectivement
mais que cela n'imprime pas forcément
est-ce que ce que c est ce que c'est
vrai a selon vous est-ce que ce jugement
et je sais peut-être pas que de la
résignation aujourd'hui là
ganisation du travail la course à la
productivité la surcharge les horaires
des structures et rendent aussi plus
compliqué le fait de de s'organiser de
prendre du temps pour pour militer pour
prendre contact avec les syndicats ou
participer à des à des initiatives et
puis c'est vrai qu'on est face à des
politiques depuis pas mal d'années voilà
qui réduisent réduisent les
investissements dans les entreprises
dans les services publics c'est
l'austérité et donc c'est vrai que c'est
pas forcément simple d'avoir des
perspectives c'est pour ça aussi qu'on a
voulu parler de ce qui se passe
concrètement dans les yvelines que les
salariés soient soit informé la
population est aussi de montrer qu'il ya
eu des choses qui ont bougé pas
forcément aussi loin qu'on aimerait mais
grâce aux mobilisations d'usagé de
salariés il ya des choses qui bougent
alors forcément cet apport pour les
yvelines cette journée mais le messager
et nationales pour pour la pour la cgt
est ce que vous avez l'impression tout
de même que vous êtes en train de perdre
la bataille on voit que la réforme sncf
certainement va passer tel quel les
blocages dans les universités ça semble
aussi l'a finie la convergence des
luttes ça semble aussi loupé pour ce
mois de mai ce que emmanuel macron et sa
politique ont gagné une nouvelle fois
j'ai envie de dire la politique du
gouvernement et pas celle qu'on
souhaitait les
les salariés puisque beaucoup de choses
n'étaient pas annoncées et un certain
nombre de choses bougent
grâce aux mobilisations au niveau de la
réforme ferroviaire par exemple bien sûr
qu'il ya des choses sur lesquelles le
gouvernement la sncf ne sont pas encore
revenus mais il ya des choses qui ont
bougé pour pas sur la dette sur les
petites lignes alors ça c'est plus
effectivement en région mais un certain
nombre de choses qui qui commence à
bouger
et puis la cgt on s'inscrit vraiment
dans un processus à long terme ou l'idée
c'est que partout les salariés puissent
s'exprimer sur leur travail comme on
voudrait bien le faire et comment
concrètement on trouve des solutions
et puis c'est après qu'on peut faire
converger ça on va en montrant qu'il ya
effectivement des politiques globales
qui sont les mêmes qui conduisent voilà
ce mal être au travail à cette perte de
sens du travail et qu'on peut
concrètement agir pour revenir au
mouvement local de jeudi il y avait deux
actions une vous le disiez défense des
services publics et aussi la campagne
pour les élections professionnelles en
décembre prochain
est ce que concrètement pour vous
désormais l'enjeu pour la cgt c'est ce
c'est le second envahir second second
évènement c'est-à-dire ces élections
professionnelles est ce que c'est ça le
plus important aujourd'hui on met pas
les choses en concurrence donc c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs qu'on a bien fait cet
événement qui est quand même assez
exceptionnelle puisqu'on a distribué en
une journée plus de douze mille tracts
donc à la fois la défense des services
publics parce que les salariés de la
fonction publique y sont attachés et
puis bien sûr ces élections là pour déjà
informées qu'elles ont lieu proposé aux
salariés qui le souhaitent d'être d'être
candidat ou nous rejoindre pour
concrètement travail et les
revendications les propositions que
défendront les représentants du
personnel
et puis informé pour le vote qui sera
dans beaucoup d'endroits électronique
mais pour peser face au gouvernement il
faut forcément être premier il ya plus
d'intérêt à bien notre but c'est
effectivement de faire le meilleur
résultat possible et de et d'être et des
deux premiers on y travaille l'an passé
dans le privé la cfdt est passé pour la
première fois devant vous en terme en
termes de suffrages est ce que vous
pensez que c'est possible aussi dans le
dans le public dans quelques mois on
travaille justement pour pour
que la cgt soit soit reconduite de voix
d'avancé
comparé au dernier vote en 2014 c'était
à peu près 600 milles pour la cgt 500
milles pour la cfdt la vence semble tout
de même confortable
est ce que vous êtes confiant comme le
disait pascal talbot nom jean baptiste
baptiste talbot dans le reportage
excusez moi on est confiant parce que
dans un certain nombre d'endroits de que
deux collectivités locales d'hôpitaux on
a mené avec les agents voilà des
bagarres qui ont permis à certains
endroits de kiki la risée des contrats
d'avenir par exemple voilà d'obtenir un
certain nombre d'avancées de maintenir
des des services même si ça reste un peu
précaire dans dans des hôpitaux
voilà dans la fonction publique d'état
aussi on se bagarre ce qu'on cherche
passé à s'implanter là où on n'est pas
encore et puis voilà échangé au maximum
avec les salariés pourrait vraiment être
porteur de leurs préoccupations
est-ce que vous pensez que le mode
d'action de la cgt jusqu'au boutiste un
peu souvent toujours opposé aux
propositions du gouvernement peut
effrayer certains sahraouis qui
pourraient être tentés de venir vers
vous mais qui se disent ah peut-être la
cfdt c'est moins brutal moins frontale
je pense que cette image là elle est
elle est plus tout à fait celle de celle
de la cgt d'aujourd'hui puisqu'on a
aussi énormément de propositions qui
passe peut-être mois voit dans l'est
dans l'immédiat que ce soit au niveau
national il ya un rapport de la
fédération cheminots ensemble pour le
faire qui dit pas on veut juste le statu
quo est on est on est bloqué voilà qui
fait des propositions pour améliorer le
service fut rien et on le décline aussi
au niveau local territoriales voilà il
ya dix jours l'union locale cgt de trois
siècles les syndicats du territoire
faisait un rassemblement et portait des
propositions en lien à la fois etc
l'industrie automobile elle fret
ferroviaire qui bénéficierait aussi
voilà la population parce que moins de
camions c'est moins de pollution moins
de bouchons à l'usure des routes
donc on a vraiment des propositions
concrètes positive on aura le temps de
vous recevoir une nouvelle fois pour
pour parler de ces élections justes pour
conclure plus de 5 millions de personnes
seront appelés à voter le 6 décembre
prochain la date et fx est dorénavant
quand on n'est pas forcément habitué du
monde syndical on a du mal parfois à
voir la différence entre tel ou tel
syndicat lors pourquoi les salariés de
la fonction publique doivent-ils voter
plus cgt que force ouvrière par exemple
pas parce que la cgt a vraiment un
travail de proximité avec des
représentants du personnel qui sont
formés qui sont en lien qui continue à
travailler donc à exercer leur métier
est en lien avec leurs collègues et qui
sont aussi en lien avec le reste de la
cgt que ce soit dans les mêmes secteurs
où ou plus largement et qu'on arrive
aussi justement à défendre les métiers
les missions des agents de la fonction
publique au travers d'initiatives plus
larges comme comme celle de jeudi à
saint quentin en yvelines
et pour rappel donc lors des dernières
élections professionnelles pour la
fonction publique c'était en décembre
votre syndicat avait réuni 23 % des voix
la cfdt 19 et force ouvrière juste un
petit peu moins 18,6 pour cent
précisément on verra du coup en décembre
si vous restez premier merci beaucoup
souvenir pour eux d'être venu sur notre
plateau d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes la responsable
départemental de la cgt
merci beaucoup et bon week-end à vous
merci à vous on passe désormais au
résumé de l'actualité de la semaine
pierre bédier était mercredi l'invité
exceptionnel du journal de la rédaction
l'occasion pour le président du conseil
départemental d'évoquer les différentes
actualités du moment et notamment la
campagne pour la présidence de la
fédération et l'ère des yvelines l'ex
secrétaire d'état fait face notamment à
la candidature à d'alexandra dublanche
vice-président de la région
ile-de-france plusieurs candidats pour
cette élection locale une mauvaise
nouvelle pour pierre bédier on
l'écoutent bouche pas de langue de bois
je penche plus il eût mieux valu comme
je les propose et alexandra et othman
qu'on intègre les intègre dans l'équipe
bon ils ne l'ont pas voulu
alexandra m'a expliqué que voilà la
diversité de candidature c'était bien ce
n'est pas ce que me disent nos militants
nos militants c'est des grands brûlés
après la débâcle d'inconnus
ils ont envie d'autre chose que ce qui
leur paraît être un peu des tensions
internes voilà donc situer hors essence
et répondit nature en octobre
traditionnellement dans le département
des yvelines on se mettait d'accord et
on essayait de constituer des équipes u
liban ça n'est pas possible cette fois
c'est vrai que il ya des stratégies
partisanes
il ya des stratégies présidentielles qui
nous font grand mal l'élection
présidentielle elle est pour après des
élections municipales après les
élections départementales après des
élections régionales
on a bien le temps de d'abord nous
préparer à nos différentes échéances
électorales avant d'aborder cette
échéance présidentielle mais c'est ainsi
on fera avec
mercredi également la ministre des
sports laura flessel et état à
guyancourt pour inaugurer le tout
nouveau sporting de brigue la structure
ouverte depuis 30 ans a subi un profond
lifting pour accueillir ses 2500
collaborateurs quotidien dans les
meilleures conditions possibles les
détails de notre journaliste sportif
forcément miquel et demi d'euros une
inauguration en grande pompe la ministre
des sports laura flessel s'est rendu ce
mercredi 30 mai au sporting de bouygues
l'occasion pour l'ancien sportif de haut
niveau de découvrir le nouveau visage de
la structure entièrement rénové pour
plusieurs millions d'euros ça donne
envie
mais aujourd'hui j'ai quand même des
talons donc du coup j'éviterai d'enfer
mais c'est vrai que ça donne envie et
puis derrière ce qui est bien aussi
c'est que c'est ouvert aussi au public
donc ça permet aussi de valoriser la
pratique pour tous le lifting comprend
notamment la rénovation des courts de
tennis des terrains de squash et des
vestiaires une zone d'équipements de
golf a également été créé une vraie
demande de la part des 2500
collaborateurs qui viennent sur le site
quotidiennement et qui trouvait l'ancien
sporting vieillissant après 30 ans
d'existence dans le cadre notamment du
vin celui qui est à la mode la qualité
de vie au travail
il est important que nos collaborateurs
puissent bénéficier des installations de
ce type
afin dé effectivement venir faire du
sport le midi le soir en toute
tranquillité avec d'installations dignes
de ce nom
en parallèle de la venue de la ministre
bouygues construction en a profité pour
signer un partenariat avec la fédération
hde handigolf objectifs permet de créer
une école de golf en faveur des
personnes handicapées
le site a également acheté une machine
pour permettre aux pratiquants de taper
la petite balle blanche
toujours pas de remplaçant à jean pierre
sevestre au conseil communautaire de
saint quentin en yvelines les élus de
l'agglomération devait lire mardi un
nouveau vice président chargé des sports
après la démission du maire de coignard
pour raisons de santé fin avril le vote
a finalement été ajournée au mois de
juin la préfecture des yvelines n'a pas
encore entériné la décision de
jean-pierre semestre
un retard qui tombe mal forcément pour
l'agglomération à quelques mois de la
ryder cup prévue fin septembre au golf
national de saint-quentin la préparation
de l'événement s'accélère le poste lui
reste vacant on écoute à ce propos le
président de l'agglomération jean michel
fourgous bien sûr que c'est on était un
peu handicapé dans cette période parce
que c'est un événement qui est porteur
de beaucoup d'activités pour pour
l'agglomération
bien sûr que on est aussi touchée par
parce par ce manque en ce moment qui qui
qui dure depuis un peu plus d'un mois
donc on souhaite que ça serait soit
résolue le plus vite possible pour bien
accompagner cet événement très important
de 55,7 en ce moment la 16e édition de
la semaine européenne du développement
durable la thématique cette année en
france et villes et territoires de
demain à cette occasion diverses
manifestations sont proposées sur le sur
le territoire justement de saint quentin
en yvelines pour qu'ils organisent ces
semaines dédiées jusqu'au 5 juin le
point sur les différents événements avec
manon varaldo sur des images de nicolas
landry et patrick jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
faire réfléchir à l'impact de nos gestes
au quotidien insisté sur le tri des
déchets un des objectifs de cette
semaine du développement durable
attrape une journée de l'environnement a
été mise en place
aujourd'hui on met en valeur surtout
notre centre technique municipal
on a mis en place des panneaux qui
explique l'historique de ce centre et on
a également une marque
on voulait mettre en place des ateliers
en lien avec la biodiversité
sensibilisation aux déchets mais aussi
atelier jardinage visite des animaux ou
encore sculpture autant d'activités
proposées pour tous les âges dans le
cadre de cette semaine du développement
durable avec la possibilité de déguster
des produits bio se verrait pourrait
jouer et apprendre des trucs pour trier
et pour apprendre les plantes et la
nature les enfants notamment apprécié
l'atelier jardinage où ils avaient la
possibilité de repartir avec leurs
plantes
ça consiste à les initier à la
plantation c'est-à-dire à transvaser du
plantier dans un godet qui étaient
achetés ou dans une jardinerie en
général
à la 3 et si vous voulez dans un
contenant un peu plus haut voilà et
tout en leur expliquant le procédé
et on les dit dans avoise 1 le
bretonneux c'est pour eux la deuxième
édition de la semaine du développement
à cette occasion un atelier cuisine afin
de lutter contre le gaspillage
alimentaire s'est déroulée en
partenariat avec l'association jardins
opération partage sa de matinée c'est de
permettre à des seigneurs de pouvoir
élaborer un plat rapidement on va dire
une heure et demie avec une entrée un
plat un dessert sur la table différents
éléments ont des paniers garnis chacun a
choisi ses éléments à commencer par
réfléchir à ses besoins
la semaine du développement durable se
poursuit jusqu'au 5 juin sur tout le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
à montigny le bretonneux la phase de
démolition de l'ancien collège bergson
se poursuit le bâtiment totalement mise
à nu dorénavant et détruit laissera
place dans quelques mois à un pôle
culturel avec un conservatoire de
musique théâtre et danse 140 logements
seront également construits comprenant
des parkings souterrains les précisions
sur l'avancement du chantier au micro de
manon varaldo et patrick jacques de
dixmude
les travaux de désamiantage et en tient
une et des travaux de curage étant
terminée donc on est vraiment maintenant
en phase de démolition et donc chaque
semaine prochaine tout le collège sera
démoli il nous restera durant tout le
mois de juin et évacuée donc maintenant
tous les to les bétons et tous les
matériaux qui ont été au prélable
séparés quand une journée sans poids
lourds à poissy jeudi les véhicules de
plus de 3 tonnes s'inquiéter est
interdit sauf pour les livraisons des
barrages filtrants ont été mis en place
en trois points stratégiques de la
commune une opération pour contrer les
mauvaises habitudes prises par les
conducteurs la ville est devenue une
zone de transit à proximité des
autoroutes a13 et a14 entraînant
évidemment pollution bruit et
embouteillages le reportage de camille
lambert
dori contrôle habite comtois à ce point
de contrôle
robespierre début de l'opération journée
sans poids lourds à poissy vingt
policiers une quinzaine d'élus et
bénévoles se sont retrouvés pour former
différentes équipes mobilisées sur trois
barrages filtrants pour nous c'est une
première il s'agit d'interdire la
circulation des poids lourds en transit
sur la commune donc sur trois axes
principaux
nous allons procéder à un contrôle des
poids lourds qui vont entrer sur la
commune nous allons leur demander s'ils
effectuent une livraison sur la grèce
sur le territoire communal et si c'est
le cas ils pourront passer si ce n'est
pas le cas ils seront invités à faire
demi tour
la bolivie
depuis 2014 la ville a déjà verbalisé
plus de 2100 poids lourds boulevard
robespierre les équipes sensibilise les
conducteurs de camions comme deux
voitures une priorité pour la commune
c'est plus d'un poids lourds toutes les
minutes qui est ici et c'est 70 % de
poids lourds qui prennent la ville de
poissy pour une zone de transit c'est
au-delà même de ce que j'imaginais
c'est insupportable parce qu'ils n'ont
pas le droit d'être là mais c'est
insupportable parce qu'il ya la
pollution évidemment à la clé et c'est
insupportable parce que sa gangrène
l'autre trafic interne à la ville de
poissy
donc on veut dire stop nous avons
constaté quand même un nette
augmentation de la circulation de poids
lourds en particulier des traverses à
des vitesses quand même assez importante
et pour nous ça devient très
problématique
même de rester dans cet appartement
à tel point pour se poser la question
comme 80% des habitants maurice souhaite
le contournement de la ville de poissy
ce type d'opération devrait être
renouvelée le maire prévoit d'organiser
des assises de la mobilité et du
transport à la rentrée c'est une
véritable composteurs à plumes chaque
année une poule peu intégré ingéré plus
tôt jusqu'à 75 kg de déchets organiques
une solution pour l'environnement qui
permet de réduire les déchets pour la
deuxième année consécutive la ville de
villepreux offert un couple de poule à
certains habitants de la commune à
camille lambert et nicolas adam drilles
ont suivi l'une des familles participant
à l'opération environnementale entre
apprentissage et bricolage reportage
charte d'adoption de deux poules
pondeuses
grâce à ce document une douzaine de
familles de villepreux vont pouvoir
accueillir chez elle
un couple de poule aujourd'hui première
réunion d'information la famille petit
wayne fait partie des candidats
sélectionnés
on en a discuté évidemment avec ma femme
et après avec avec les chiens on était
ravi de d'avoir de savoir l'idée d'avoir
de poule 2 poule à la maison qui nous
qui nous donnent des oeufs et je trouve
que l'initiative en fait est vraiment
intéressante l'idée d'avoir des poules
dans le jardin également le regarder les
sorties
ouvrir les portes et oui leur donner à
manger changer la litière et où une
opération menée par la ville pour la
deuxième année
adoptez la poule attitude s'inscrit dans
une démarche écologique
l'objectif principal c'est la réduction
des déchets parce qu'avec une foule en
fête une poule mangent jusqu'à 70 75 kg
de déchets de cuisine parents donc avec
deux poules 150 kg de moins par an c'est
quand même conséquent ça y est encore
c'est au minimum 1 pour accueillir ces
petits composteurs à plumes la famille
s'active dans la construction du
poulailler la future maison des
nouvelles locataires déjà très très joli
très pratique avec plein de verture qui
vont nous faciliter la tâche pour
nettoyer le poulailler pour lui donner à
manger pour leur donner à manger
après une heure et demi de montage le
poulailler est fin prêt jenny et molly
rejoigne la famille et découvrir leur
nouvel environnement
on sait ce qu'elle mange on sait quand
elles vont pondre
on sait de quoi ils sont faits c'est nos
yeux qui viennent le jazz en fait on les
prend et on les mange c'est tout à
toutes les deux de génie et molly
réduiront 250 kg les déchets du foyer et
nourriront la famille une poule rousse
peut pondre jusqu'à 200 heures par an
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo autour
de l'actualité à lundi à 18h sur tv 78
bon week-end à tous et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]